hahaha [ __ ] it what the [ __ ] what the
[ __ ] man oh [ __ ] man in a you still
after me isn't he oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] oh
[ __ ] oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] ah oh oh oh god
damn it oh hey you're a sawed-off
[ __ ] [ __ ] where's it's gonna send
me what was I supposed to do oh no oh no
no are you kidding me are you [ __ ]
with me
what hello everybody my name is
markiplier and welcome back to leave um
this game was just the biggest dick hole
I've ever seen anything be a dick hole
like I cannot believe it would send me
back that far like unbelievably that far
so I just wanted to say that so you know
why I'm back here but we're gonna fast
forward obviously to the place where I
just was so you won't lose too much
progress it'll be fine whatever
man and I'll I didn't get all the notes
that I had there were a bunch of crap
around here though so I'll be back I'm
getting back to the place but I'm just
pissed off and it is [ __ ] [ __ ]
you know it's [ __ ] [ __ ] wow that
took a while to get back here ah pretty
douchey pretty douchey cannot lie pretty
douchey pretty damn douchey you don't
see me do you I got the barrel of
disguise it's the barrel of invisibility
you'll never find me
do not what are you doing go away he
went away last time what is this
[ __ ] how [ __ ] it got me after it
didn't give me it finally got me [ __ ]
you [ __ ] you okay we're officially back
was good yeah we're back okay so I know
what I need to do and god damn it I
passed by it again why is this so easy
to pass by so this is a loop this is a
loop with these vents and what I need to
do is I need to get a yellow thing from
beyond that way where the guy is
guarding put it here so that I can grab
it through there that's why I got there
and that's the thing that I need to be
able to move on but to get that I got to
get it from over here which means that I
gotta get by him so if he runs after me
which I have a funny feeling he's gonna
cuz he's an [ __ ] like that oh I
thought that was a noise
can't see can't see can't see is so dark
okay so he's not gunning for me Lake
like he did last time which is weird but
it's also good because here are my
batches of things that I need and I just
need to get him out of there and then
take it with me [ __ ] I gotta be able to
there we go ah got it okay so I got this
mr. O handy that so that's probably a
way back yeah okay I know where this is
[ __ ] just got to be careful cuz if
he's lurking around
I might have to bail and run okay looks
like he's skedaddled so all I got to do
is I can actually drop this over on the
other side crawl through and then I
should be good okay so it looks like
he's leaving me alone then why did he
kill me last time what did I do
did I smell bad was I offensive in some
way I don't know man I cannot believe
that they didn't put in like a
checkpoint system in between that
because if they're gonna put a monster
like there's every chance especially if
the monster is actually lethal there's
every chance that it could die the
player could die and like having to go
all the way back like that's
ridiculously far back to go on so anyway
besides the point okay so have
that's not half how about half no okay
so I gotta hit it
go go go go go honorable move it about
buh buh buh buh buh buh buh buh buh buh
no okay what am I missing
no god damn it oh god damn it okay so I
knew something god damn and I'm such an
idiot
this has individual controls on this
pipe here like here's a confusing thing
this is why it's confusing because if
you hit it once it'll go all the way but
if you hit it again it'll stop and I did
not know that I was operating on the
assumption was all or nothing thing okay
and then it's at half we hit the button
and it opens okay so I'm an idiot and
that took way longer than it should have
but thankfully you guys wouldn't have
wasted your time with seeing all that
you guys just tossed it to the end so
hooray hey man I cannot believe how long
that took I had to play through all of
that again I'm still a little pissed
about it why am i back here why am i
back here did I open something did I fix
something I was just back here because
it was being a [ __ ] to work always
working great cool fine
whoa cutscene huh oh hey oh my golly ah
all my blood um well that was
tantalizing once again right up in the
exit why do you keep doing that I wonder
what kind of horrid experiment took
place here my mother could she still be
alive somewhere on this island
I doubt it after all that I've seen this
all feels strangely familiar why am I
being chased who are they I bet they
carry many of the answers I seek if only
insanity had not claimed them first yeah
and if only you hadn't been knocked out
had something penetrating your gullet
and then
sighing hello are you the good doctor hi
okay it's wonderful that you're
excellent the sousaphone wow that didn't
come out right I'm sorry but it's
wonderful that you're excellent at the
sousaphone which is what I meant to say
in would have been funny in context but
now I'm explaining it too much and it's
it not funny
okay well oh good my shitbucket is here
prefilled most excellent thank you sir
so intense she was on cutting off the
child's limbs as she didn't notice her
victim was long dead she Pierce what
remained of the body with the blade that
had crudely attached to her wrists
replacing what was once her soft and
caring hand the dirty sac on her head
covered her face but could not mask her
anger what a sight she was to behold
standing among her young victims her
torn clothes drenched in blood
they're soft skulls cracking open under
the weight of her boots as she walked
towards me a sound well-known to us both
a real monster yet she is better off a
monster than a coward like me it's been
32 years since that fateful event and I
haven't left her side ever since what
this sounds like a love letter towards
the end there whoo boy whoo Nellie
something weird is going off here also I
remember a scene in amnesia where I was
in a prison is there a brick in the wall
that I need to pull with my psychic
powers it be but you weren't counting on
that douche-nozzles
easy peasy lemon squeeze me all right
what else we have food what about this
is beef jerky my precious room is gone
it had been taken from me I knew every
single stone by name and now all my
beloved friends are gone today will once
again be the first is this another test
I wonder I suspect the guards know but
they never speak the footsteps tell
their stories but I need more practice
they haven't noticed yet but I have
something feels different in this cell
we have been transferred no doubt but
there's something else - okay that's
confusing I'm not on a percent sure what
you're talking about but
a glug down some blue goo and hopefully
that's gonna help me on my journey man
that should have posted the guard to me
unless there's only a few of them left
which there very well might be whoever
was coming up behind me by the way was
also very stiff snippy very quick okay
goddess everything just seems to be open
around here hip I said hit me there we
go
Oh what does that do
sounded like it just locked me in how do
you do that it did it did lock me in
what was the point of that oh okay
hello ah ooh so it's black yeah
the smell of burning incense made my
blood run cold
I could hear two or three men laughing
and cursing I worried less about the
first two but Jacob I had seen him
hunting prey ripping off limbs with his
bare hands as if he was drawing pleasure
from it I walked around the house
following the sound of their footsteps
peeking over the edge of the kitchen
window I thought maybe I could trick
them somehow perhaps make some noise and
lead them to the front door so she could
jump through the window and escape but I
was too late okay I'm very confused one
why are these notes here and two what
are you talking about sounds like a
family home but from what I've been able
to tell this Debenham like a mineshaft I
mean everything's gone horribly wrong
here don't get me wrong but he Hammond
stop no well what was the point of
pulling all that off oh [ __ ] whoops no
no well no one keep trying yeah No
BAM oh that didn't work
man I was actually kind of hard to do oh
yeah
break you [ __ ] I didn't break it it
[ __ ] croc there okay now that we got
that this is open a bold now we go down
here okay into the pit of doom I say
splish Splash oh boy that's not what I
wanted Oh oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ]
oh hello that was a very excitable jump
okay
don't seem good wherever the hell I am
nothing over there huh okay hey okay
alrighty then
hello hey oh that one's stuck stuck
we have been cast into eternal darkness
for it is our fate to carry this burden
shadows grow in our finite minds haunted
by our guilt and yet we chant with heavy
breath the fabric of life being
stretched out far and wide from this
place the weeping of its threads
piercing my ears right before they break
into a thousand stars as this a mockery
of the gods are you trying to be poetic
cuz wasn't very good just confusing
these are these Oh balls
can i light them on fire it look like
can I let no okay never mind then
that would be too interesting okay so
what was I supposed to do down here was
I supposed to do anything or is this
another place with a mysterious node in
it damn it it was just another place of
the mysterious note in a sticky stupid
son of a [ __ ] how am I supposed to be
able to do this it bit ah okay so what
do I need some oil to do that how about
this yeah yeah no [ __ ] okay that didn't
work and I can't open that so there's
got to be something else or there's got
to be some way to get that lubed up cuz
if I know one thing about horror games
they sure love to use their Lube oh
never mind I just come over here into
the new area where there's obviously new
things hello hi she sat on her favorite
chair as one of the men kept twisting
her arm almost as if he was enjoying her
screams and it looked like he wanted
more Jacob pushed her head down firmly
on the table and ordered the third man
to pull out the last box of incense I
couldn't really tell if they used it for
their ritual or just to match their own
masks their own
he grabbed her and pulled her head back
and said almost whispering it's time I
could see that she tried hard to hold it
in but the awful smell is a final drop
Nagi took over her body in fluid sprung
Oh God
with each coughs she struggled for air
and finally he violently smashed her
face into the table place no human
beings cut should be capable of
committing such an atrocious act if that
was exactly what I had witnessed an
otherworldly scream escaped her crimson
lips while he was holding the back of
her neck like a captured animal [ __ ] man
oh my god that's horrifying why oh why
seriously none of this makes sense why
are there rampaging bands of horrible
monsters and killing people in the
countryside and and why are people
writing about it down here where am i
this is supposed to be a mineshaft it
looks like a a frickin castle dungeon
who built this egg it seemed like they
were doing scientific studies here but
it all seems just like medieval
architecture who bill oh god hello uh
why did the fly sound like moaning who
build this okay moving on up bill uh-huh
besides who witnessed that damn rodents
they keep coming back however many traps
I place something draws them to this
place I wonder what it could be uh maybe
all the dead bodies oh so your bear trap
man [ __ ] you was there really nothing to
this is there really no reason for this
there must have been a reason for this
hello I see you haboos
hey wait whoa whoa where are you going
did you fall down yes you did somehow
okay give me you Oh Oh No I thought that
was something over here
man this is just bizarre okay so what am
I supposed to do am I supposed to light
something on fire burn this brush I am
Hibou ski I'm smart I am smart I'm smart
look at me I'm smart I was lovely when I
actually get something because I so
don't often do man seeking a while to
burn come on hurry up already ain't got
all day
urn down burn the whole [ __ ] down burn
this whole castle down whatever the hell
it is I mean it's obviously not normal
is it [ __ ] [ __ ] you oh whoa did that
worker was it just time I have no idea
which well [ __ ] I guess I gotta walk
across hot embers you get out of here
okay here we go ouch ouch Gibble's okay
I probably should've waited till that
cooled but I didn't have time to get got
the laughs am yeah okay right now
jeez ins so many places to go
oh oh okay I suppose we've entered the
fire portion of the game okay why and
how and what am I supposed to do here oh
there's a checkpoint in there good god
that better actually saved for me
because if it hasn't saved yet I will be
so pissed I'm gonna get to that and then
I'm gonna end this episode here cuz I've
been playing this particular one for way
too long trying to get to where I was
supposed to be what's the point of this
okay so far so do so far so goo [ __ ]
god dammit with your [ __ ] house I
supposed to know
[ __ ] off do not kill me if you kill me
with this [ __ ] I swear ah where I
looked there was nothing good God better
not be more those take a huge chunk of
my health huge chunk
he gave us Incan paper to record his
work how kind of him I keep smiling
every day to show my devotion
that's all he desired from us but no one
understood I knew all along in the end
he only wanted to secured so you're
probably all talking about dr. rue
burning ham Brinn bringe in him Loretta
Brogan Stein I can't remember yeah Wow
this better have gotten me to that
goddamn checkpoint where the [ __ ] did it
draw me where the Frick did it drop me
wait where is this where am I now
oh here the buzz oh man I probably got
turned around again maybe back over this
way
thought I was gonna drop me on the thing
oh my god
I'm back at the beginning what the [ __ ]
but was this open
I'm back at the beginning but what how
did I get back here I didn't want to
come back here oh god damn it okay
trap okay
guess it's something [ __ ] man stop it
stop it with that you're such a dick
well there's nothing over here why
didn't I come back there's no reason to
come back is there another one I [ __ ]
swear I [ __ ] swear so far so goo but
why did I man I didn't want to drop down
if I hadn't known it was gonna come back
here I wouldn't have dropped down dammit
okay that opened that what could that do
how about this yeah okay that helps may
be locked seems like a way out over
there I mean this definitely is a
medieval castle [ __ ] wait fog front back
oh [ __ ]
I'm out of stamina no do not kill me now
do not do not I'm out of stamina you
[ __ ] [ __ ] if you if you [ __ ]
kill me I swear oh you [ __ ] oh you
[ __ ] oh you [ __ ] oh if you kill me oh
if you kill me if you kill me I will
never ever forgive you game it's our way
to open this goddamn gate [ __ ] you [ __ ]
you so hard game you son of a [ __ ]
okay who's that oh god oh god oh god oh
god I'm good
oh [ __ ] oh good ah no not that way I saw
the trap I saw it okay can I die Oh what
are you [ __ ] kidding me
good god why did I die what was I
supposed to do I went the way I was
guided and I'm punished by going back
[ __ ] god damn it what the [ __ ] all
right I guess we're done with this
episode but holy [ __ ] are you kidding me
what else was I supposed to do was I not
supposed to go towards freedom because
oh no that's punished worthy god damn it
okay I don't want to be pissed at this
game but that's just bad gameplay
alright anyway I'm Anne and this episode
before I start rambling too much about
how pissed I am but maybe I should have
made a better choice but it seemed like
the only obvious one it was like run
[ __ ] and I brand so either way thank
you everybody so much for watching and
as always I will see you in the next
video bye bye
because I'm not doing this on four I'm
legit Wow
I'm jittery trying here before back to
who and one why wait wait what happened
who was that bus before